okay
I think thanks very much for that
introduction yeah so I'm going to be
talking about the contextual bandits
problem so just to start off with
something concrete I thought I'd give a
kind of motivating example of where the
kind of problem we're going to be
looking at comes up so if you design a
website then the website needs to decide
on the content or the advertisements
that will be presented to each web user
as he or she arrives so what happens
repeatedly is the website is visited by
a user and that user generally shows up
with some kind of profile or some
browsing history in other words you know
something about the user typically then
the website has to decide on an
advertisement to present to the user or
a newspaper article or some other
content to present to the user and then
finally the user responds in some way so
the user clicks or leaves the page or
whatever and the goal of course is to
make choices that will elicit some kind
of desired behaviors so most typically
the website wants to try to get the
person to click as much as possible as
often as possible so here's another
example so this example is to medical
treatment so the other example is a very
realistic example this one is maybe a
little bit more science fictiony but
whatever it still brings across the main
ideas so in medical treatment what
happens is that repeatedly a doctor is
visited by a patient and then again of
course the doctor knows something about
that patient so the doctor knows about
the person's symptoms and test results
and the person's age and gender and so
on I'm based on all that information the
doctor needs to decide on a treat
and prescribes a drug does nothing
whatever and then the patient responds
in some way so maybe the person gets
better or gets worse or never comes back
and that happens you know repeatedly and
the goal of course is to make choices
that will maximize favorable outcomes
you want patients to get better okay so
both of these are examples of what we
call the contextual bandits problem
what's called the contextual bandits
problem so what's happening is
repeatedly some kind of agents like the
doctor or the website needs to decide on
an action so in this talk I'm going to
be called calling that agent a learner
since I come from machine learning and
anything interesting is done by a
learner so the learner repeatedly is
presented with some kind of context like
information about the patient or the web
user then the learner decides on an
action like prescribing a drug and then
finally the learner observed some kind
of reward where that reward could be
positive or negative we're thinking of
it as a real number but importantly the
learner only gets that reward for the
actions that was actually chosen that's
what makes this a bandit problem the
bandit name come comes about for
historical reasons from an older problem
called the multi-armed bandit problem
and this version of it is called the
contextual bandits problem because of
the context of course okay so this
happens repeatedly in the goal is to
learn to choose actions to maximize the
rewards so what we claim is that this is
a very general and fundamental problem
it's really the problem of how to learn
to make smart choices smart decisions
intelligent behavior through experience
okay so what are some of the issues that
come up with a
so priest father is a classic dilemma
which comes up in any bandit problem
it's often called the exploitation
versus exploration dilemma so on the one
hand the learner wants to exploit what
has already been learned so as to behave
in a way that will maximize rewards
based on what's already been learned
that's exploitation but on the other
hand if you always act in the way that
you think is best based on your
experience
you might be missing out on other great
ways of behaving new drugs to be
discovered whatever and so we also need
to be doing some exploration so that we
can learn new behaviors we can learn
behaviors which might give better
results
so that's the first dilemma how to
balance between those two in addition in
the contextual bandits problem we have
to use the cut we want to use the
context as effectively as possible so
when you have contexts there are just
many many more ways of behaving there
are many possible ways of behaving in
other words of choosing actions choosing
how you'll make decisions based on
context and so there's just a lot more
possible behaviors to consider and of
course it's very unlikely that you're
going to see the same context twice or
maybe you'll see the same patient a few
times but in general you're dealing with
a large collection of patients all of
which might be different so what that
means is you can't be learning
separately for each context we have to
figure out a way of generalizing across
context and another important issue or
problem we'll have to deal with its
selection bias because we're going to be
trying to gather statistics through
exploration but we're also exploiting at
the same time so you're both gathering
statistics while trying to maximize
reward while trying to behave in a smart
way and that means that the statistics
that you are gathering will be very
highly biased you're getting
it's very highly skewed data and so
somehow we have to deal with that and
then finally we want our methods to be
efficient we care about space and time
efficiency okay so these are some of the
issues that make this a challenging
problem so in this talk I was told that
this is a broad scientific audience so
I'm going to try to give an introductory
overview of some of the algorithms and
techniques that have been developed for
this problem and I'll also talk about
some of the variants on this basic
problem what we're aiming for our
algorithms that are very general purpose
and practical so they should be fast we
want them to be easy to implement and we
want them to be capable of learning
complex behaviors we want to be able to
learn complex ways of choosing actions
based on context and we also want these
algorithms to have nice statistical
properties we want them to be provably
as statistically efficient as possible
okay okay so here's a quick outline and
they should say - feel free to ask
questions here's a quick outline so
first I'll start by formalizing what the
learning problem is here then the main
part of the talk will be about
algorithms and techniques and then
depending if there's time I'll talk
about an application of this and the
next step ok so starting with
formalizing the learning problem so let
me start by giving a formal model or
formal presentation of the problem that
I already talked about so this is really
the same problem that I talked about
before but just with some math notation
filled in so we've got this process
which is repeating so there are capital
T rounds or trials
in which this is happening and on each
round little T what happens is that the
learner observes some context that will
denote X T and then the learner selects
an action a T and make things simple
we'll assume that the actions that there
are K possible actions where K is you
know think of K is not too big a number
10 may be a hundred possible actions and
we'll just number those actions 1
through K and then the learner observes
a reward a real-valued reward
importantly for the one action that was
selected yes so let me say where the
rewards come from okay so this is okay
let me say what RT is okay I'm actually
leaving out a step here there's another
step in here which is that before the
learner selects an action nature or the
world or the environment whatever you
want to call it selects a reward vector
in other words selects the rewards that
would be received for each one of the K
possible actions and by the way we're
assuming that the rewards are in a
bounded space let's say between zero and
one okay so this reward vector is chosen
this set of rewards for any possible
action that the learner might take are
chosen by the world before the learner
selects an action then the learner
selects an action and the learner gets
to see what the reward is for that
action okay so to answer your question
this notation looks like a function but
don't think of it as a function it's a
vector that was chosen beforehand okay
okay and the goal at least the goal for
now I'm going to refine this but the
goal is to maximize the total reward the
sum of the rewards that would be
received for the action selected okay
now for now for now I'm going to assume
that these contexts and these reward
vectors are being chosen at random at
every time step
independently from one trial to the next
okay so I'm not I'm not saying that
contact X T and R T are independent of
each other that would mean the contacts
carries no information about the rewards
on the contrary we expect these to be
very highly correlated and we expect
that the context will be informative in
choosing which action gives highest
reward I'm just saying from one round T
to another for now we're assuming that
everything is independent okay okay so
just to make this concrete here's a
little toy example so in this example
there are three possible actions so on
the first round let's say a web user
shows up and we have a description of
that web user he's male he's 50 years
old and so on and then nature chooses
the reward for each one of the three
possible actions and of course that's
not revealed to the learner
then the learner selects one of those
actions so the learner maybe selects
action two gets to see the reward for
action - but not for the other action
and receive that reward and then we'll
go on to the second round another
context shows up nature chooses the
rewards for each action the learner
selects an action gets a reward and so
on okay so the learner is building up
the sum of rewards that it's trying to
maximize okay so the learner is trying
to figure out how to choose actions
based on context in other words what the
learner is trying to do is the learner
is trying to find a rule a decision rule
for selecting selecting action from the
context okay a rule for selecting action
from the context and we call that kind
of a rule a policy it's called a policy
okay so the learner is trying to find a
good way of choosing actions from
context
so just to make things concrete here's
an example of a possible policy that the
learner might try to use to select
actions and again this is just meant as
an example I'm not saying that we always
use policies that look like this but
what this policy does is given a context
let's say a web user this rule says if
the web user is male and choose action -
otherwise if she's over 45 2001
otherwise choose action 3 so the point
is it just gives us a way of selecting
actions based on context when a new
context comes in and the learner is
trying to learn a policy of that kind so
a policy again need not have this form
in general a policy is really just a
function that map's any context to an
action that's all it does give this way
of selecting an action and where do
these policies come from well before
learning begins we as the algorithm
designer needs to decide on the general
form of the policies that we'll be using
and really this is just like what
happens in machine in all kinds of areas
of machine learning where before you do
any learning you need to decide ahead of
time what kind of a rule you're using so
you might decide to use a decision tree
or a neural network or a linear
classifier and so on so in the same way
as the algorithm designers we need to
decide on the form of the policies that
will be used which is to say that we
need to decide on policy space of space
of functions of space of policies that
that we'll be using
okay so for example we might be decide
to use decision trees in that case the
policy space would be the space of all
decision trees a decision tree if you
haven't seen it it's just been nested
if/then/else rule like this that's all
of these dozen tree
okay just as an example so passively
what we're doing when we decide on a
policy space is we're making an
assumption we're making an assumption
that there is some policy some rule in
that space which will give high reward
and of course the algorithm designers we
don't know if that will be correct or
not but it's something that where we use
our background knowledge and our
intuition and so on to make that
decision okay okay so those are policies
and policy spaces so the goal then once
we've decided on a policy space is to
learn through experimentation to do as
well as the best policy in the space or
almost as well as the best policy in
that space so in other words if there is
one policy in the space which is good
which gives high reward then our aim is
to come up with a learning algorithm
which will perform nearly as well as
that best policy okay that's how we're
formulating the problem so in general
where I've done it in general but for
simplicity it's not in general but for
simplicity I'm going to be assuming that
this policy space is finite but even
though it's finite we're typically
thinking of it as being extremely large
a huge space like the space of all
decision trees which is a huge space
okay so we're thinking of this space is
being exponentially large exponential
and whatever complexity measure you want
okay but a huge space but finite and by
allowing that space to be so huge we're
allowing for the possibility of learning
behaviors which might be very complex
behaviors which can express complex ways
of choosing actions from context okay
and the hope is that this is going to be
a very powerful approach but there are
challenges of course okay there are
challenges when dealing with this really
really large policy space because when
you have a very very large policy space
we need to be learning
out all of the policies at the same time
while simultaneously trying to perform
as well as the best one and when an
action is selected we only get to
observe the reward for policies that
would have chosen that same action if a
particular policy would have chosen a
different action we don't know what
reward it would have received so in
other words it's the same exploration
versus exploitation dilemma but now it's
on a gigantic scale it's on a gigantic
scale because you're trying to learn as
well as the best policy in this gigantic
space okay so we can go back to this
formal model and we can make it more
precise so this first part is unchanged
exactly what I had before but now we can
refine what the goal is before I said
vaguely that the goal is to get high
total reward so now to make that more
precise what we really want is to get
high total or equivalently
equivalently high average reward
relative to we're in comparison to the
best policy in the policy space so if
there's one good policy then this
learning algorithm should also perform
well even if we don't know what it is
when we start out ok so we can measure
that difference in performance by what's
called the regress so this is the
regress don't worry too much about the
math but basically this term is the
average reward of the learner just
averaged over the capital T trials and
this is the average reward of the best
policy in the space capital PI and so
the difference is the difference in
performance and what we want is for that
regrets be small in particular we want
to regret to go to zero as the number of
trials gets large which means that the
performance of the learner is getting
very close to the performance of the
best policy and if we can do that we
call it a no regret learning algorithm
okay okay so that's that's the learning
model that's a description of the
learning problem so what I want to do
next is to start talking about
algorithms and techniques for solving
this problem and in fact this part is
broken up into two parts the first part
is the full information setting I'll say
what that is in a minute and then we'll
come back to the bandit setting okay so
as I said we'll start with the full
information setting so to make things
simpler what I want to do is to start
out by supposing that the learner
actually gets to see the rewards for all
of the actions not just the action that
was actually selected okay so in terms
of medical treatment that would mean
that when the doctor prescribes a drug
he also finds out not only what happened
with that drug but what would have
happened with a host of other treatment
of course this is not at all realistic
in medical treatment but let's just go
with it okay to build intuition okay so
the picture is like this again a context
arrives nature chooses a set of rewards
the learner chooses an action but now
what's different is that the learnt
learner also gets to see what reward
would have been received by all of the
actions including the ones that were not
selected okay so this process goes on
just as before now what makes this
setting nice what makes it nice is we
can pick any particular policy and
figure out what rewards would have been
received for that policy okay so we can
pick a particular policy PI let's call
it and we can go back and we can compute
what actions would have been selected by
that policy on each one of these
contexts it's just a function so we can
figure it out did you have a question
yes after the action is chosen that's
correct okay so we can figure out what
action would have been selected by that
policy and since we can observe all the
rewards we can also figure out what
reward would have been received for each
one of those actions okay so we can
figure out the total reward that would
have been received if we is listened to
that one policy all the way through it
and of course we can do that for all of
the policies and that's nice because if
we just take the average of these
numbers the average of these that
average is a good estimate of the
policies expected reward remember we're
in a random model an iid model okay so
that you can talk about expected reward
and this average is going to be a good
estimate of the expected reward so
there's a really obvious thing to do
here which is just you've got a policy
space you can compute the reward the
total reward of all of them just pick
the best one right so we call that
simple algorithm to follow the leader'
algorithm so and follow the leader on
every round all we do is we find the
empirically best policy the one that's
performed the best so far in terms of
its chosen action and then we use that
policy on the current context to select
the next faction eighty that's the whole
algorithm
okay this algorithm gives optimal regret
so the regret of this algorithm is like
square root log number of policies
divided by T so this means that the
regret is going to zero at the rate one
over square root of T okay so it's a no
regret algorithm and you can see it's
only logarithmic in the number of
policies which is what we want because
we won't be able to we deal with these
exponentially large policies so
statistically this is great but what
about computation
well the main challenge in terms of
computation is this step how do we find
the best policy in the space now there's
no general answer to that but what we
need what we need to implement this
really simple algorithm is we need a
method for finding the best policy in
this space
okay so we're calling that procedure
whatever it is in Oracle we're just
calling it in Oracle I realize some
statistics Oracle means something a
little bit different and in any case it
sounds like a mysterious word but all I
mean by miracle Oracle
Oracle is not a miracle and Oracle is
just an algorithm or a subroutine for
finding the best policy in this space
the best one on the contexts and rewards
that were actually observed okay so if
we have an Oracle like that then we can
use it to implement this algorithm so we
call this Oracle an Arg max Oracle it's
also called erm Oracle classification
Oracle and so on the important point is
not what it's called the important point
is that this Oracle is actually doing
something that's really natural in
machine learning so we've been talking
about things like actions and policies
and so on but in fact all that's
happening here with this Oracle is it's
solving a very standard kind of learning
problem called a classification learning
problem where you're trying to classify
objects according to their category okay
so if we change the name of everything
change the names of policies and actions
and contexts we just end up with a very
standard kind of classification learning
algorithm and that's great because
people have been working on that problem
for decades and so by now we have all
kinds of methods that we can use here we
can use support vector machines and
decision tree algorithms by car dempsey
4.5 we can use
boosting we can use neural networks
there I said it
so I said deep neural mass okay but
seriously if you have a good
classification algorithm sitting around
for the policy space then we can use it
in place of this Oracle okay I saw a
hand go up yeah the target or the label
would be just the action would just be
the action yes I do I wasn't going to go
into technical details but basically
policy corresponds to a classifier and
context corresponds to an example or
instance and then the actions correspond
to the labels or the classes yeah and it
just ends up being a straight mapping
okay good okay so I'm just going to kind
of highlight techniques as they come up
those kind of general techniques that
are coming up and even though this is
such a simple algorithm there are a
couple techniques that come out of it
the first is to estimate the expected
reward of each policy from empirical
data which we're doing and another
technique is to use an existing method
in Oracle as I'm calling it to find the
best policy okay two techniques that
we'll come back to okay let's see by the
way what time am I supposed to stop I
know I was supposed to start ten minutes
late okay okay so maybe I won't talk
about proof ideas proof ideas just to
show that every policies empirical
average is close to its expected reward
and then you just do a little math and
you get a regret bound
let me move on so so far we assumed a
stochastic setting where the contexts
and rewards are chosen
iid independently and identically
distributed on every round T but that's
not always realistic like you could have
correlations and the data you could have
drifting data or you could be in a truly
adversarial setting like in a game
playing setting so sometimes it's nice
to work in a setting where you don't
make these stochastic assumptions that's
called a non stochastic or an
adversarial setting so in that case the
contexts and rewards can be entirely
arbitrary they might not be assumed to
be random and they might even be chosen
by an adversary
so in that case follow-the-leader will
not work it's not that hard to come up
with examples where an adversary can
cause the learner a learning algorithm
like follow-the-leader to suffer very
low reward to have very low reward while
at the same time making sure that at
least one of the policies actually does
have high rewards on that way you
forcing large regrets
so follow-the-leader will not work here
but there's another algorithm that will
work here which is called hedge hedges
the algorithm I did with Yao Freud but
it's really based very directly on the
weighted majority algorithm of
Littlestone empowerment so in hedge what
we do is we maintain one weight one
real-valued weight for every policy in
the space and on every round what we do
is we first choose one policy at random
with probability proportional to those
weights so in other words we normalize
the waste and then we just choose a
policy at random according to that
distribution and then we use that policy
to select an action just like we did
before
okay so we just use the weights to
choose a policy and use the policy to
choose inaction and then once we observe
the rewards we can increase the weight
of every policy according to the rewards
that was received so the higher the
reward the more we increase the weight
of the policy okay so over time you're
putting more and more weight on the
better policies very simple algorithm
this algorithm also yields optimal
regrets same regretted follow the leader
but now it does it even in the
adversarial setting which is really nice
but the problem with this algorithm is
that it needs to maintain a weight for
every single policy so at least naively
the time and space requirements of this
algorithm grow linearly with the size of
the policy space so it's just going to
be too slow and generally infeasible if
the space is gigantic actually maybe
I'll forget that since I'm a little
behind in time okay but so here we've
gotten another technique the technique
is to use a weighted combination of the
policies another very useful technique
okay so when you prove an amazing result
like this is to use the technique used
by Littlestone environment which is to
keep track of the sum of the weights of
all of the policies and it turns out
it's possible to prove an upper bound on
the sum of the weights in terms of the
reward of the algorithm and you can also
prove a lower bound on the sum of the
weight in terms of the reward of the
best policy and then when you combine
those sounds you get or we gret boned
okay so comparing these two so-so
follow-the-leader is for the stochastic
setting hedges for non stochastic they
both give optimal regret one is
efficient if given access to an Oracle
the other is inefficient
if the policy space is gigantic is it
possible to do both is it possible to
get an algorithm which is no regret and
is efficient given access to an Oracle
and which works in an adversarial
setting the answer appears to be no it
appears to be impossible this is due to
Hassan and quarry I say appear because
every time I ask him a lot cause on the
first author we always have this long
discussion do we show that to anyway so
I think the answer is it's impossible
okay
okay so moving on to the Bandit setting
okay so in the Bandit setting of course
we only see rewards for the actions that
were taken ok so again the setting is
the same as full information setting but
the learner does not get to see rewards
for actions that were not taken so the
learner can still compute its own total
reward but what happens if we try to do
what we did before with
follow-the-leader well we can pick a
policy PI and we can figure out what
actions would have been taken by that
policy but of course we don't get to see
the rewards for all the actions that
were taken by the policy so on round one
maybe this policy two would have taken
action 3 but since the learner did not
pick action 3 the learner picked action
two we don't get to see what reward
would have been received by the policy
so we only get to see the reward for a
policy if it happened to take the same
action as the learner ok so we can't do
what we did before we might like to use
an Oracle in the way we did before for
follow-the-leader but there are some
real problems with it the problems are
that we only get to see some of the
rewards for any particular policy and in
addition the rewards that we do get to
see will be very highly biased because
again
choosing actions to maximize reward and
that means the statistics we're
gathering will be very highly skewed
okay so in case it's not clear already
exploration is really important in the
band that's setting so just to drive
that home just as a little tiny concrete
example imagine that we're considering
two drugs and the truth is that the
first drug drug a is pretty good maybe
it has curate of 60% drug B is a lot
better it's got a cure rate of 80% but
what can happen in early trials is it's
possible it's possible that just by
chance the first drug might start to
look better than the second drug drug a
might look better than drug B even
though B is actually better and if that
happens an algorithm like
follow-the-leader will get stuck and
will only pick a it'll say oh a looks
better than B so I'm only going to try
drug a which means that statistics for
drug a gets better and better but the
statistics for drug B stay lousy because
we're not trying it okay so we get stuck
it becomes a vicious cycle where we're
only picking drug a so the point is that
we need exploration all the more so when
you have these complex policies so in
fact we can use a modified form of
follow-the-leader which is called
epsilon greedy or epoch greedy by
Langford and Jung so this is like
follow-the-leader but we now have this
explicit exploitation and exploration so
the algorithm is like this so on every
round we choose actions in one of two
ways so with 99% probability and letting
f1 be 1% so with 99% probability we'll
just choose the best policy so far in
the same way as follow-the-leader
and then with 1% probability we'll just
choose one of the actions uniformly at
random
okay so this first part is explicitly
doing exploitation using what we've
learned so far and the second part is
explicitly doing a form of exploration
and by the way this first part as with
follow-the-leader we can do efficiently
if we have access to an Oracle so this
is an Oracle efficient algorithm so it's
simple it's fast if we have an Oracle
the product and its analysis is a lot
like follow the leader the problem with
it is that the regret you get is not
optimal
so the regret you get if you choose
epsilon carefully is like K the number
of actions times log number of policies
divided by T the number of rounds but
now to the 1/3 power so the optimal
regret would be the same but with square
root rather than cubic group okay so
that's too bad but we did introduce a
new technique here which is to do
explicit exploration by doing this
uniform sampling of action some of the
time okay what about oh okay so another
problem I brought up quite a bit is
selection bias so let's talk about
selection bias for a minute so I've been
saying that bias is such a big problem
but actually there's a very simple and
old trick for dealing with bias which is
called inverse propensity waiting so
just to illustrate what this technique
is very simple suppose we want to
estimate the expected value of some
random variable X okay so let's say this
is probability and on fair coin comes up
heads so X is one of has zero of tails
and to make it more interesting let's
suppose that we only get to observe X
with probability P so we observe X with
probability P once and otherwise with
probability 1 minus P we don't get to
observe X
at all we don't get to get any
observations of this random variable
which is kind of like this setting we
have in the bandit setting for any
particular action you might get to see
the reward for that action but you might
not and it's with some probability well
there's a trick we can use here we can
define a new random variable let me call
it X hat which is just equal to X so the
observed outcome of this coin flip let's
say divided by P the probability we got
to observe it if we actually got to
observe it or zero otherwise
okay so what's even though we only some
of the time get to observe X what's nice
is we can always observe X hat X hat is
always observed in all cases and what's
also nice is that the expected value of
X hat is the same as the expected value
of AK seep I can do the calculation in
your head to see that okay so X hat
gives us an unbiased estimate of the
expected value of X so it's a nice
little trick and we can use it in the
bandit setting to get unbiased estimates
for the rewards of all of the actions
not just the actions that were observed
so great we can get these on biased
estimates does that mean we're done well
no absolutely not because if you're not
careful the variance of these estimates
might be extremely large so even though
I've been talking about bias as being
the problem
bias actually is not the problem we can
get unbiased estimates the real problem
is controlling the variance of those
estimates okay and sometimes we can do
that just with uniform sampling of
actions and sometimes we need something
more sophisticated okay okay so another
technique inverse propensity waiting to
get unbiased estimate
okay so what about the non-stochastic
setting so f our greedy which for the
stochastic setting what about bandits in
an adversarial setting when that setting
there is an algorithm called XP for for
contextual bandits in an adversarial or
non stochastic setting so this algorithm
combines three things I've already
talked about it combines hedge so it's a
lot like hedge but we also combine it
with uniform sampling of actions which
actually is sometimes optional depending
on the particular learning problem
you're looking at and finally we also
use the inverse propensity weighting so
if you combine all those and you do
things carefully you can get the optimal
regret which is the same as what we had
for epic greedy but with the square root
rather than a cubic root okay and of
course this also works for adversarial
data not just stochastic data okay and
the analysis is a lot like hedge but we
also have to worry about marryin okay
but the problem with it is that again
just like hedge the time and space are
linear in the size of the policy space
so we not getting efficiency okay so to
summarize these quickly or to compare
them epic radius for stochastic setting
XP 4 is for the non stochastic setting
if a greedy
gives you a regret bound which is not
optimal it's like 1 over cubic root of T
and it's efficient if we have access to
an Oracle where as with X before we do
get optimal regret like 1 over square
root of T but it's not efficient so
these differences in regret might not
look so big 1/3 1/2 what's the big deal
but these really are big differences ok
they really are big differences so to
get a regret of Epsilon
where epsilon is some small positive
number in the first case we would need
like 1 over epsilon cubed examples
whereas for X before we would only need
like 1 over epsilon squared trials so
that's a big difference in the amount of
data that you need to get an equivalent
performance equivalent statistical
performance so can we get both so if
we're in the stochastic setting is there
an algorithm which is fast with an
Oracle that gives optimal or near
optimal regret and the answer is yes so
let me explain that last this is the
last algorithm I'll talk about which is
called well it's official name is I
loved con bandits I don't remember where
this name comes from but we mostly call
it by its nickname which is mini-monster
actually there's at least one co-author
in this so well I won't point them out
to see if he knows remembers why we
called it that anyway
so in this mini monster algorithm
basically apply all of the techniques
that I've talked about so far all of the
techniques I've talked about so far and
in particular just like in hedge we need
to compute a weighted combination of the
policy's heads uses a weighted
combination of policies and this
algorithm does also in the same way but
now we're going to find the weights in a
different way we're going to look for
the weight and we're going to start by
writing down a set of properties that we
want those weights
to satisfy we're going to write down Q
constraints that we want those weights
to satisfy so first of all we want the
weight to give us a combination of
policies which gives us low regret low
regret according to our current
statistical estimates in other words we
just want to choose actions that we
think will give high reward and on the
other hand we want to choose
we want to be choosing actions in a way
that controls variance we also want to
get low variance on our estimates that
we're getting now and which we will be
using in the future so we want to make
sure that our future estimates are
accurate by controlling the variance now
so we can write both of these down as
constraints mathematically and these
just correspond directly to exploitation
and exploration in the first case you
know you're just trying to get high
reward that's exploiting what you've
already learned and the second case
you're trying to make sure that your
estimates in the future will be accurate
and you're doing that by doing a form of
exploration okay so we can write down
what these constraints are we can
formulate it as this big optimization
problem it's not actually an
optimization problem it's a constraint
satisfaction problem in any case the
important thing is that it's really big
and really complex by really big I mean
you have exponentially many variables
and even though I wrote this as two
constraints when you break them down you
actually have exponentially many
constraint as well so it's a huge
optimization problem but nevertheless
we're able to solve it using a very
simple and very efficient algorithm
provided that would give an access to an
Oracle the main idea of the algorithm is
just to find violated constraint and fix
it and repeat until done but of course
the interesting part is coming up with
an algorithm which is simple and which
is guaranteed to converge quickly so
once you do all that the regret of this
algorithm is almost optimal so we get
that square root we also get some logs
factors that I'm hiding with the soft o
notation that's why I say almost optimal
and it's really fast so it's really fast
in the sense that we can measure how
fast it is by how often it calls the
Oracle because that's the real
computational bottleneck and it's
calling this Oracle less than once per
hour
less than once per round so it's calling
the Oracle on average about square root
of K over T log number of policies time
to like 1 over square root of T times
per round or said differently about once
every square root of T rounds hey when
people ask that question yeah the bigger
the policy face the less often you call
the Oracle I don't know why that is I
don't know we made up some reasoning of
after the fact of why that is and I
don't think we were that convinced so
it's basically you know you set things
up and you have these different things
you have to trade off and when you work
out the trade off this is what you end
up with and you know you are getting a
certain amount of information every time
you call the Oracle which will be more
if you have the policy space so a bigger
policy space so maybe that has something
to do with it I don't know sorry yeah
sorry oh oh I see um yeah I guess I
can't do that in my head but yeah maybe
maybe that that's a nicer way of looking
at it I'll think about that afterwards
oh good yeah the number of rounds to get
a particular act regret okay good so
this this technique that we're using is
based on previous work by do dica at all
their algorithm was called officially
randomized UCP but it was a rather
complex algorithm it was complex enough
and the methods were complex enough that
came to be called a monster paper or the
monster algorithm so that's where that's
where it comes from so this this mini
monster is is much simpler and a lot
faster
so whereas this previous method was
calling the Oracle something like T to
the fourth times every round ours again
is only calling the Oracle less than
once per round
okay so the technique here is to
formulate the desired properties in the
form of an optimization problem and to
solve it okay so let me say a word about
the how we prove this so to prove the
regret bound we can prove the regret
bound just using the constraints
directly so the regret constraint
meaning that first constraint that I had
up before basically ensures that will be
getting low regret provided that we have
good estimates of the reward of every
policy and the variance constraint
ensures that we actually can get
estimates that will be good enough this
assumes that we can solve the
optimization problem and then to prove
that we can solve the optimization
problem and to drive bounds on its
efficiency how fast it is how many times
you have to call the Oracle we use a
potential function that measures the
progress of this algorithm and we show
that every time every iteration of this
numerical algorithm that we're using to
solve the optimization problem causes us
to make a good amount of progress and
the total of Prague's amount of progress
we need to solve it is bounded until
that gives us a bound on how fast it is
okay so things like I'm out of time so
let me just mention an application and
then I'll stop so some people in our lab
in New York and elsewhere and Microsoft
have created a system that basically
implements contextual bandit problems
they call it the multi world testing
decision service and this is a system
computer system it's meant to be
general-purpose and modular so you can
use all these different kinds
contextual bandit algorithms use it for
all kinds of applications and they
they've set it up so that it's really
easy to interface with an existing
system when I say system I mean you know
a real system like you know what's
running the Microsoft we add the MSN
website for instance which is one place
that's been used and it's especially
been designed to reduce common errors
you'd be surprised how hard it is to
collect data in a reliable way and so by
creating the system they'd be eliminated
a lot of the problems in creating these
systems and in particular it's been
deployed to select news articles on the
MSN homepage so as a test example and in
this particular case they tried quite a
few learning methods before this one and
none of them had been successful had
done better than the humans who were
selecting news articles by hand before
this by using this system they were
actually possible to get a 25 percent
relative list or improvement in the
click-through rate so it's a big
improvement and so now it's used to
handle thousands of requests per second
ok so I'll skip this since I'm out of
time and so so basically I try to
convince you that this is a challenging
and interesting problem challenging not
necessarily unsolvable and I've tried to
run through some of the main some of the
methods that have been useful in solving
it and so stop there
[Applause]